the second of the gold medalist it is a
film that was made at the Pratt
Institute of New York by Zach higher and
in the film is entitled correspondence I
never thought I'd be standing here
accepting an Academy Award this is
totally unbelievable first I'd like to
thank the academy for this experience as
it's been such a great honor to be
recognized by this prestigious
organization the time here in LA has
been so amazing all the events at the
academy that Academy organized for us
and being able to meet so many people
working this field has been so inspiring
it's such a privilege to be including
this talented group of Student Award
winners it's really motivating me to
continue doing creative work in this
field after spending so much time on
this project and only having your peers
as an audience you really don't know how
be received once you release to the
public standing here tonight it confirms
that was all worthwhile I want to thank
my composure Jin soo kim who I really
enjoyed working with his music talent
really helped bring my animation to
another level I would also like to thank
my parents my two brothers and my sister
who always supported and encouraged me
whatever I want to pursue I want to
thank my girlfriend Maki for her
unwavering consistent support of my
project but also like to thank pratt
institute in the department of digital
arts for all the guidance i received
from their faculty that's it thank you
so much